Be remarkable!
If you want to have success in business
you have to get people to want to talk
about your company.
You don’t have the money to spend on huge ads
that go on and the Super Bowl
and TV ads, radio show ads, right,
you don’t have that budget.
You want to have success you need people
to talk about your business
and that comes from being remarkable.
Think about the word,
remarkable.
It means make a remark about something.
Why should people make a remark
about your company?
You have to give them a reason.
If you don’t, you’re dead in the water.
You’re not going to achieve
success with your company.
You’re going to be an average or mediocre business.